There's a few things that I'd like you
to clean up now that we actually have
user data to use and users logging in.
First, I'd like you to remove
all mention of Anonymous Owner.
We know who the logged in users are now,
so
we shouldn't need to fall back on this.
Instead, you should store the email
address of the current user.
I'd also like you to finish the goal we
had in all of this, which was to change
the main activity screen to show the
user's name and then lists, like this.
We're also using the encoded
version of their email
as the key to their user data entry.
Because of this, if we simply have
the encoded email everywhere in the app,
we can easily load up any
associated data with the user.
When the user logs in
in the login activity,
we have access to their email
through the off data object.
And at that point we can encode it,
which I'd like you to do in step three.
And the fourth thing
that I'd like you to do,
is to store the encoded email as
the current user in shared preferences.
You should also store the provider
that's being used there as well.
This will be helpful because it
will allow you to easily grab this
information anywhere from the app.
It also makes this information
available to us on load,
if the user happens to close the app.
Okay, the full spec is on its way,
let me transfer it.